so what causes hurricanes like harvey to
form in the first place
here with some answers is michio kaku a
cbs news science contributor
and city university of new york physics
professor professor good morning
glad to be on the show so when you look
at the storm as it sits right now
hanging over texas what concerns you
most about harvey
several things first of all if it
lingers over the land it could cause
massive flooding and then watch out if
it goes back into the gulf it could get
re-energized and create a second even a
third
landfall and so the agony has just begun
with this hurricane of the decade
let's talk about the science behind
hurricanes how actually do they form
well believe it or not the hurricane is
sort of like a bowling ball
they form off the coast of africa as a
small breeze and then they gather
energy as they go toward warm water
across the atlantic
and then if it comes in just right it'll
get a strike it'll go into the gulf of
mexico
get energized by the warm water or it
could be a gutter ball
and simply veer off in the direction a
wrong direction
this hurricane went right through into
the gulf got energized by the
by the warm water and now hitting that
fuel of the warm water what about the
speed because it was
moving faster and slowed down what's the
impact there
well when it hits landfall you have
friction plus it no longer is energized
by the warm water beneath it
and so it's a velocity drops enormously
and it goes from category four to
category one
within a matter of hours after his
landfall but watch out
if it goes back into the water you get
re-energized and the nightmare starts
all over again
yeah because we're we're still
experiencing even in a category one
we're still
dealing with with flooding and storm
surges yes that's right and just
remember that the
the gulf of mexico is two degrees warmer
than normal
and that has set off alarm bells in
washington
just last month the government issued a
warning stating that because
of the warm waters of the gulf of mexico
this hurricane season
which goes on until the end of november
could be one of the worst in memory
so watch out there could be more monster
hurricanes to come
and that's the theory that climate
change is impacting all of this
well we're not sure okay however there's
no smoking gun
but it is consistent with the fact that
the gulf is warming up
and that is the energy that is driving
these monster hurricanes
and according to the government this
hurricane season watch out
right we've been talking about storm
surges all morning what what exactly
causes a storm surge
well storm surges could be 12 13 feet
tall
and as the waves that are whipped around
at 130 miles an hour hit landfall
sometimes they get bunched up as they go
toward land and that's why you get these
huge
monster waves hitting the coast coming
in at 130 miles an hour
i feel like we've talked a lot about
some of the different storms that have
hit and maybe at some of its comparison
take something like super storm sandy in
comparison to harvey
or even katrina can you make any kind of
comparison with those
yes sandy had caused about 70 billion
dollars in property
damage and it was only a category three
but it went right up the northeast
causing tremendous flooding and damage
in a very heavily populated
and uh very uh densely populated area
and katrina was category five it had
property damage about a hundred billion
dollars
and it actually uh created uh cracks
in the levees which then flooded new
orleans now here we don't have that
situation
but i think it's gonna be up there it's
gonna be up there and perhaps i'm
among the top 10 say that because this
hurricane is a monster hurricane it's
130 miles an hour wind it's lingering
it's
stationary right now it could cause a
tremendous amount of flooding
blackouts evacuations and it can get
re-energized again so we're just seeing
the beginning of the agony
dr michoaca thanks so much for being
with us this morning